the class today is supposed to have been
strategic ideas and just the IV I had
prepared and I a lecture about outposts
in the center it's a really really good
one it's a pity that I won't be
delivering it instead I got as usual
sidetracked by events that are happening
around the world what's happening is
there's a major event going on in
Thessaloniki in Greece and today I got a
Kamsky the US Champion of 2013 played
against Hikaru Nakamura is black the
2012 US Champion and when these two guys
meet you know well you know this
beautiful idea of a strategic lecture
well that just went right out the window
and I spent my morning uh watching this
game unfold and it is a fantastic game
and a quick story there is that before
the US Championship Kamsky had come from
sukh Switzerland he arrived literally
jetlag completely gone barely made the
opening ceremony was half asleep and
then he won the US Championship with a
4-0 start oh yeah I think it was a 4-0
start followed by five draws oh yeah it
was lucky he goes from the US
Championship immediately to New York to
say hello to his folks there then he
goes to Moscow his home changes his
suitcase
goes to sessile on iki greece where he
did he start with a wind been regatta I
have an impression he well yeah exactly
I I believe it was round one but then he
goes on to where he is today which is in
first place in tehsil Nietzsche it's
like how does he do it I just amazed
because jetlag plays havoc with my
system and I've travelled all over the
world and despite 35 years of great
experience dealing with jet lag I've
never managed I always get nailed it's
just like really really really really
bad and well here he is playing a very
crucial matchup not only for the
tournament but just in terms of the
rivalry that these two players have
between themselves it's very clear that
they stand number one and number two the
thing that's always been in dispute is
who's number 1 and number 2
well of the last few years we have to
give the edge to Hikaru not only because
of his extraordinary rating in the world
of chess but just what he's managed to
accomplish and most especially in 2012
in the very last round he caught on
needing to win with the black pieces did
precisely that in Pinole team it round
pardon me and defeated gada and went on
to clinch in the US Championship Ghana
however he stuck to his guns in 2012 he
played efore and lost in a very
straightforward way to Sicilian in this
game Hikaru very well not very
surprisingly but surprising to myself
played ecigs I think in this particular
round there was something like who five
with E 5 ie 4 E 5 just dominated today's
round and lots of reuleaux passes by
white players the French defenseless
play d4 d5 92 the tarush defense I loved
playing the French defense as a kid 9
little I especially liked to play
against the Knights III the winner were
variation and it always bugged me as and
after after E 5 c5 or actually my
favorite move was 97 here and after a 3
I was very cagey with the black pieces
and I would play for b6 and Bishop a6
but it always annoyed me when my
opponents played Knight d2
I didn't have a really you know good
answer for 92 yes no well the idea
behind 92 is as simple as white is
defending the pawn on e4 and he's
looking to avoid the Bishop b4 pin
because he simply has c3 so the idea is
simply to avoid Bishop b4 now deal when
my opponents played Knight d2 against me
and I would go with with the straight
forward variation the line that I didn't
like with black is that my opponents
would build up what we called the big
center or the center clamp
you know white has this very nice chain
of ponds all the way to e5 and black's
knight if he doesn't manage to solve the
problem with the knight on D 7 black can
get into trouble early a favorite move
of mine in this position was I used to
play rook b8 the idea was several fold
first of all I was very anxious perhaps
more anxious than I needed to be as
black I wanted to solve this Bishop on
c8 and the idea of B of rook b8 was that
after my opponents played Bishop d3 I
would play b5 they would play 92 I would
play b4 they would probably play
something like castles and I would play
moves like Queen b6 here and my aim is
to well besides you know a good
demonstration of your activity on the
Queen side frankly speaking I was
playing for Bishop a6 but again my my
results weren't that great with black
and 92 was a very big problem for me and
it wasn't only my problem
it was a problem of Viktor Korchnoi and
in 1974 Viktor Korchnoi played a match
for the candidates final it was a 24
game match against Anatoly Karpov
Anatoly Karpin up in those days his
repertoire was specifically 92 and
Korchnoi would played c5 e takes d5 he
takes d5 Knight here knight c6 Bishop b5
and he to end up defending a sum ending
like this which I'm about to show you an
isolated queen pawn kind of position and
basically Karpov tortured him
fortunately achieved a lot a lot of
draws but he had a hell of a time with
black in this isolated queen pawn middle
gained and game that often came out of
this opening so in those days this this
match in 1974 was played in the Soviet
Union an Anatoly Karpov
was the Soviet chess Federation's choice
in the upcoming contest against Bobby
Fischer so Anatoly Karpov had a huge
revenue of chess grandmasters that were
supporting him and Viktor Korchnoi help
was essentially Yoshi Murray grandmaster
who now lives in Israel and Yasha Murray
said to Korchnoi that this this line was
c5 with is ending that that corner was
getting was very uncomfortable and and
he had a bishop move on move three four
four courts noitu play and that same
evening a cautionary received a call
from grandmaster roman gingy Havel II
who was secretly helping Viktor Korchnoi
because roman and roman didn't want to
get into trouble with the soviet
authorities by openly helping Korchnoi
and roman said Victor I've got a great
idea for you on move three move your
Bishop he says yes yes yes Marie told me
I should play Bishop d7 with the idea of
going into the Fort Knox variation after
takes takes Knight takes Bishop c6
Bishop d3 Yasha wants me to play this
ending that this middle game with 97 and
followed by Bishop e7 and Knight f6 no
no no no says Roman gingerschilling
not Bishop d7 Bishop e7 that's the move
that you want to play Bishop e7 well I
adopted this move many years ago Bishop
e7 because I really liked it it somehow
and this moment the the lines c5 takes
takes
didn't appeal to me the line a six
followed by c5 takes takes those didn't
appeal to me either
sorry let me just put that on the board
so a6 is it is considered a normal move
Knight f3 c5 and so what's the big
difference well the big difference is is
that White's Bishop f1 doesn't get to go
to this nice square b5 and after for
example a line like Bishop e2 knight c6
castles the bishop isn't that well
placed on e 2 even there's a line where
black plays C 5 C 4 if he is afraid of
the isolated queen pawn position okay
sorry what did I do something wrong
sorry here let me just get on my glasses
so that's a six that was the line with a
sex correct Nigeria
sorry c5 takes takes Bishop e2 knight c6
castles deep on and that this is this is
a very common sequence that after Knight
b3 thanks to the Queen black a white
will we capture the pawn on d4 and well
it's just a line of play and again I
personally don't like this line very
much for black and so I was seeking it
answers to Knight d2 and I like the move
Bishop e7 because and it's in a very
strange way the line with Knight f6 597
f4 kind of plays into White's hands so
the idea of Bishop e7 makes really a lot
of sense like okay it's your turn with
white what are you going to do
if you play a move for example like e5
here first of all it's not coming with
the tempo and then after c5 c3 Knight
comes out quickly and Queen comes to b6
quickly and white is a little bit wrong
footed if black if white plays this move
C 2 C 3 which is what black is actually
trying to induce well one idea is that
now that White has committed excuse me
white has committed himself to playing C
3 before I play C 5 well my idea is
black was to go into the Rubinstein
French variation which is this where
I've included the move Bishop e7 and
White has very kindly included the move
C 3 okay
it's not like that everybody who plays
the French defense wants to take on e4
and that was not Hikaru his choice he
played c5 and now this strange move e5
was played okay a strange move normal
move it's kind of like an advanced
French
where black is played Bishop e7 a little
bit iffy not the greatest move but on
the other hand in an advanced French
it's not very common for white to put
his knight on D to so early so I thought
that black is doing quite okay
Knight G f3 and now this cute little
move Bishop d3 essentially in the
opening it's a constant fight as both
players are trying to find harmony for
their pieces so before this move knight
c6 so very rudely interrupts White's
flow White has got to imagine what would
be an ideal setup for his pieces well if
he if he had his druthers and black
didn't bother him he'd like to play
Bishop d3
you'd like to play this Knight to e2
he'd like the castle and he'd like to
put this knight on f3 then this the pawn
on d4 would be very very well protected
and black would simply suffer a cramp in
the center okay
so blacks idea is as straightforward as
it can be which is not to allow white to
harmonize his pieces as I've just showed
Bishop d3 Bishop Knight c6 Bishop d3
okay so now it takes on d4 takes on d4
and a crucial position has been reached
you very much if you were black you'd be
elated to capture this pawn on d4 the
problem with Knight takes d4 is simply
that after Queen g4 it's simply too good
whites threat of Queen g7 or Queen d4
essentially is winning for white hence
we see Knight h6 Knight f3 and now this
very double-edged risky move by Hikaru
in this position which has been reached
before several times I should say Knight
f5 has been the standard way of playing
it this kind of way of play for black is
very standard obviously you're still not
threatening to capture on d4 lots of
times because in the end there's a check
a discover check and you lose your queen
and very often a move like g4 Black is
ready to meet this move with Knight to
h4 ok in this position Queen b6 let's
say let me just put in another move for
a moment castles and let's say Bishop d7
so again now at long last black is ready
for a lot of grabbing on the d4 square
why could grab this Knight on
five and you get a position like this
and this is very very debatable after
move for example like NIDA for the
debate is this Bishop is ugly it's a big
bad bishop it it's the bad bad bad bad
bishop the bishop that we all like to
avoid but grandmaster from romania
hey well remember his name in a moment
had this wonderful wonderful quote bad
bishops defend good pons okay these are
good pawns these pawns on d5 an f5 are
very good Michael Shuba yeah and he did
he bad bishops defend good pawns and
even though this bishop looks bad in
blacks mine he could Castle and one day
play ideas like h6 in g5 and force that
night to capture that bad bishop but
that was not something that he karo was
interested in and instead he played the
move
f7 f6 very very risky double edge which
it suits her karo and he basically said
I invite you to capture my night on h6
and double my pawns and goddess said
thank you very much I'll do that takes
Knight e to now what do we have going on
here well in reality the position is
extraordinarily sharp black has these
horrible horrible pawns on h6 and h7 but
he's got some other pluses in the
position the first and most important is
that black has the two bishops if black
could ever in a fantasy capture this
pawn on e5 weak force black white pardon
me to recapture this pawn on
with the pond it's a very good chance
that this pond can be won how well you
could play your rook to f8 and you could
sacrifice your rook as one another is
you might play Queen to c7 and simply
take the pawn the one really bad thing
about blacks position is that these
pawns being really a poor shield it
usually means that blacks King is going
Queen site so if black could play moves
like Queen b6 Bishop d7 castles long he
might be able to turn the fact that this
pawn is terrible on h6 into an advantage
of potential attack down the G file so
in short the position is still full of
mystery I don't know Queen b6 and here's
start number one of the mystery I think
it would have been better for black to
play check just check if white plays
Queen to d2 besides the fact that I
could consider the move Bishop b4 which
is probably very good after Queen d2 I'm
happy to go into an ending after the
trade of Queens Queen takes D to say
king takes D to this part these pawns
are not that vulnerable and after Bishop
d7 and castles I think black is doing
well I'm pretty sure that gada would
have played King F 1 he's played these
types of ideas with white very often in
his career and his problem with his King
on f1 is that his rook on h1 but is in
trouble
the gada usually solves this by playing
h4 rook h3 and so on but I do think that
Queen a5 check was the best move yes
Knight to c3 is a good it's a very good
move as well and yes exactly and you can
worry about castling later and things
like that the idea goes back to the
question that I started with which is
really about peace harmony in a sense
the knight on c3 is okay it's not that
great when White Knight was on e - what
White's ambitions were involved was
maybe to play Knight f4 and to really go
after this pawn on e6 the problem is is
that the knight on c3 for example after
say Bishop d7 let's just put some moves
on the board for just a moment castles
castles we get a position probably it's
in White's favor still but it's again
doubled double-edged edged double-edged
yeah that's right yeah that's it and I
don't know I have enough experience with
a French to say that it's not all
display on one goal there's a lot
there's a lot that's going to happen
over the next few moves white of course
is going to go a3 before black is going
to move his king he's going to move his
rook his Queen which isn't great on the
Queen side it's probably going to come
back to d8 or maybe c7 depends yes yeah
yes in forward yes yes I totally agreed
that oftentimes in the French defense
thanks to this pawn on e5 the d6 square
is kind of like a magnet for whites
pieces like you really like to put a
knight on d6 but as we saw I mean okay
black took this horrible obligation of
these pawns but he got this dark squared
bishop in return yeah well again it's
with the King on the Queen side but
black is hoping that he might be able to
use the opportunity of the half-open G
file to try to provoke white and again
in a dream world just fantasy dream if
you could as black if you could force
the exchange of f6 for the d4 pawn
there's even ideas of Bishop e8 bishop
g6 as well as Bishop h5 in short I'm
saying it's a double-edged position and
I did like Queen 85 as opposed to the
car was choice Queen b6 castles because
now I don't know if he karo thought
seriously that his with the Queen on b6
what's the idea of the Queen on b6 well
it's got two ideas principally the first
is to capture the pawn on d4 well that's
not happening you are not capturing the
pawn on d4 because it's defended too
many times night on e to knight on f3
Queen on d1 and the second idea of Queen
on b6 o capture this one you know don't
give me the the d4 pawn I'll take the B
to pawn
so here I don't he Carlo played the move
Bishop d7
and I'm pretty sure he didn't seriously
consider the MU Queen takes b2 but I'm
an old pond grubber yeah I would have
seriously considered I mean you know if
you did if you play Queen b6 well you
know your your your idea and intention
is to follow up with Queen takes b2 the
problem is after Queen takes b2 let's
just put a move on the board
rook b1 for a moment and let's just go
all in whole hog as we say Queen takes a
- well here the problem is I see it is
blacks King now that the B file is open
you're probably not playing Bishop d7
and allowing rook takes beset yet that's
a that's a thought let me just finish
what I want
Queen B - let me just finish so we get
here and you're not playing Bishop d7
well if you're not playing Bishop d7
what are you doing with your King and
that's a darn good question after the
move Queen C 1 we see instantly the
drawback behind these double pawns as I
see it why to sacrifice two pawns but he
is absolutely going to get back this one
oops how come I can't draw arrows well I
don't know why I can't draw arrows okay
but he's absolutely going to play Queen
takes h6 Queen g7 as a follow up idea
you might want to try to shut things
down but it's not going to be that easy
and I don't think you want to play night
before and allow moves like Bishop b5
check so I think that this would have
been an extremely risky pawn grab and I
like pawn grabbing so that was a bit too
much
the gentleman suggested another concept
Queen takes b2 Queen a
for okay the problem keep in mind that
as a French defense player I really
really like training Queens I mean as
black I want to get the Queen's off I
feel that I really reduce White's
attacking power tremendously by trading
Queens it's something I really aspire
for in the French so after a move like
Queen a for one instinctive move would
be Queen before another instinctive move
would be queen a3 queen a3 I kind of
like simply to get out of this stuff
over here and if if you take bishop
takes and if you take here I'll be
pretty happy with that I think I can
deal with that either with King and King
or maybe just simply castles yeah
Queen c2 Arnie Queen c2 night before is
already starting to be a little bit
tricky I don't think I'd go for night
before right away
I'm not had I'd be very happy to lose
this pawn on h7 so for example Bishop d7
I'd be very pleased that you spent so
much time grabbing this pawn on h7 and
maybe putting your pieces a little bit
away from blacks King escape
yeah and that's very interesting when
you play against the French defense and
your opponent is playing very
provocative the move Knight h6 is a very
provocative move I think at that moment
after Bishop takes h6 and gh there's no
safety anymore I think you have to stop
thinking like oh I want to grind him out
or something like that I think you just
go whole hog like Queen takes b2 you go
rook be one Queen takes a two and you're
just very very happy that the that the
game is a mess you know and keep in mind
you know the mass is that really this
King is not safe it's not safe
it's kind of a tough life the life of
the the black King and a French defense
it's not really that safe on the Kings
side and it often times because of that
safe in the green side and it often
times isn't safe in the center when the
French King really starts to like the
situation is when the Queen's are off
and it's getting more towards an endgame
as opposed to a middle game okay so far
so good everything's normal
Bishop d7 and now you know in the good
old days and I thinking of myself as you
know growing up as a kid disposition
well you know I know what I do in an
instant here as a class player I'll
probably play the move rook b1 yet as an
expert master player I would play a3 and
I congratulate myself on my
understanding yet the idea of a3 is you
know I of course want to play the move
b4 and you know grab some space and
since this
a weakness you know I turn a weakness
into a strength because I'd be wanting
to play b4 and b5 and drive this night
away so you know as a class player to
play rook b1 and as an expert master I
play a three but as a world-class
Grandmaster B four whoa this move really
you know gets like 12 stars you know
like whoa you know you're just not
supposed to be able to do that you know
because there are three count'em black
pieces that can take this pawn and white
is basically saying please do me a favor
take my pawn on b4 interestingly enough
and Hikaru declined declined the
opportunity to take the pawn on b4 first
of all how many of you would have
considered the move before yeah baby you
know like okay it didn't I didn't I
think in some very very vague recesses
of my consciousness I may have
considered it but really I mean it's
sort of like what I was saying is like
a3 became my sophisticated kind of move
just because I thought okay Queen takes
b2 rupee one Queen takes a three rook
takes b7 let's get it on let's go let's
go crazy after a3 no idea I have no idea
probably he should probably
as he did in the game which was maybe
castles before king b8 something like
that is maybe how black has to walk into
this attack and again I have convinced
myself that a 3 and B 4 were very good
depending that we do receive exactly so
rook b1 again the class move would play
rook b1 for all of the reasons not least
of which is by the way ideas such as b4
and then you cannot capture because a3
well you just win material one thing
that you have to be a little bit leery
of or where we other how I'm not exactly
sure how to put that is in some cases
perhaps not directly here there's this
move Knight before which is a kind of an
annoying move black essentially wants to
solve the problem of his d7 Bishop he
simply wants to take take and play
Bishop to b5 ok so not that night before
is necessarily the best move for black
in response rook v1 but that's something
to be considered and that's why I
personally like to move a three you cut
out night before and you're ready for
before but there's no question that this
move b4 is actually the strongest move
and here he karo played a6 and the game
continued that was what I wanted to ask
you guys you know like hey I mean you
know my question is is like why didn't
black capture the pawn well first we can
deal with Queen takes b4 we just discard
that almost instantly as thank you very
very very much
you've just allowed White's rook into
the heart of blacks camp and you've made
it impossible for black to Castle long
and it's terrible okay so quaint eggs
before we can reject Bishop takes before
we could probably reject for you know
another reason that we kind of pedantic
but there it is is well after captures
on f6 I just don't like this position
one bit for black essentially rook be
195 this pawn is pretty darn good on f6
and after all that's a huge outpost so I
don't like trading the b2 pawn for the
f6 pawn how about instead Knight takes
b4
okay so Knight takes before that
certainly it is worth considering and a
moment ago I mentioned that night before
to try to take this Bishop works out
very well for black so let's imagine
rook to b1 pinning the knight to the
Queen let's imagine that a to a3 is a
real threat and so Queen a5 getting off
the the pin but unfortunately from
blacks point of view Queen d2 Queen at
Queen c7 instead of Queen a5 and come to
that a moment what it does to me - we'll
see we'll see why in a moment the Queen
d2 this just looks first of all I'm
threatening to capture on f6 winning
back my pawn I love doing that and you
still haven't sold very well at least
this you could go back with your knight
but then I'm going to take the pawn on
h6 and my rook on b1 is very good let's
go back a second pardon me Queen a not
Queen a5 but we at Queen c7 was
suggested Queen c7 the problem as I see
it is again is that white is simply
ready to capture this
pawn on f6 and that that that the bishop
tempo just you know like it was really
like an AA move
yeah removing the guard okay before
Knight takes before here rook here yeah
yes and now retreat the night no I think
I'm going to capture here sorry I beg
your pardon
Queen takes h6 now in this position
besides threatening to capture on f6
another problem that you should be very
aware of is Bishop check rook takes b7
in other words White's having a lot of
fun here he hasn't sacrificed that much
in terms of the goods the goodies and
blacks King is facing all kinds of
threats I'm absolutely sure he karo
didn't want anything to do with these
variations but the problem from hey
Carlos point of view is this move b5 is
really a you know a pain and you know
painful move to have to address
he played a6 which I think was fine and
then here again you know you have this
safety play if you like you know this
idea that you know you haven't burned
any bridges why not just play it a nice
little safe move like a2 a3 you know you
expanded nicely on the queenside blacks
king is not going to be very happy if he
goes long after moves like Queen d2 and
rook B 1 and B Phi
I'm very happy that this pawn on a6 is a
target so you know why could play and
move like a three and just simply keep
the position right but this is again
this is a kind of a situation where
white should not be thinking in such
terms but rather thinking you know he's
got to go full out and just absolutely
try to refute blacks entire play Queen
d2 very nice move takes on e5 takes on
e5 in a sense you know the how do you
say the ante is getting higher okay
after this trade of 'if I've which black
has been wanting to do for quite some
time remember how this pawn on f6 was
this constant you know you had to you
know there was a knight on b4 that after
a takes f6 somehow is it this attempt oh
well black is now very happy he solved
that problem that he now no longer has
to worry about
he takes f6 constantly above him but on
the other hand something else that's
even more insidious has appeared and
that is the square d4 from a strategic
point of view it would really be
dreadful for for black to allow white or
to let white establish a knight on d4 a
9 on d4 with this pawn on b4 this night
would be involved would be invulnerable
I understand right now the Queen is
covering the square d4 but just from a
strategic point of view white could ever
play knight on Eid 2 to d4 he'd have
this incredibly powerful Knight in the
middle of the board and this Bishop on
d7 really genuinely sucks well he would
take it twice
Bishop g6 wins McQueen that's a that's
that's the well we're assuming black
makes some move here you know but I'm
just saying that Knight d4 is a scary
strategic threat that black is facing
and he he has to do something about that
well
hikaru he's a he's a resourceful rascal
I can't I I give him a great deal of
credit for that here he came up with
Queen tags before Queen takes h6 Queen
a3 and that move I didn't like Queen a3
I thought that the whole fight now has
to shift and the new battleground at
least from blacks point of view the
theater that he wants to create as the
battleground is the king side and here I
just didn't like the move Queen a3
because frankly speaking that isn't the
battleground what's going on over here I
thought that oops excuse me I thought
the crucial move here from blacks point
of view was Queen g4 okay so the idea of
Queen g4 first and foremost I don't like
my King getting chat right like video
Jesus like I don't want to have to deal
with ideas like Queen g7 either I'm not
not really happy about those things yeah
all kinds of nasty things so first of
all Queen g4 no I'm not saying this is a
good move or a bad move it is a move and
I can imagine a lot of players wanting
to play h3 and just drive the Queen back
and I was just thinking that after this
move Queen g8 again blacks position
isn't that great but at least you know
if I were black in this position I give
myself a shout I would be thinking well
I've protected ecigs my queen okay it's
a little half-assed at the moment but it
is on the file I'm dreaming i'm dreaming
of castling long and I'm dreaming that
I'll be able to play castles rook d8
takes two FA takes f3 and I'll grab this
pawn on e5 as compensation I thought
this was crucial the main line Queen a3
struck me as somehow fundamentally wrong
that the Queen on a3 really does not
have a say in the game and on g8
although it looks a little defensive it
also has offensive purposes after this
situation I think Kamsky played
absolutely flawless game from here on
out like Hikaru essentially after this
move has no chance check King moved to
d8 Bishop here so the first the first
problem emerges oh dear
what are we going to do about this pawn
on e6 and if that pawn falls that King
on d8 is going to be next
stick the Queen back on g8 for a moment
well at least you wouldn't be facing
those issues now Hikaru was you know in
full mode of trying to save the game he
played rook f8 bishop takes c6 and rook
takes f3 this is a you know a lot of
people you know in these open sicilians
they understand the rook c8 rook takes
c3 exchange sacrifices right but if you
play through about the 6,000 or so
Viktor Korchnoi games where he plays the
French too
I would say in a good percentage of them
he's sacrificing a rook uh against f3 in
this case not only was it forced well
it's just the only way of gaining any
play otherwise the collapse of the d5
pawn and the exposed blacks King it
would be over takes Queen takes f3
Knight g3 now it's funny and I hate it
actually the computers here I think
everybody then I think you'd agree you'd
play you slapped down knight g3 in a
blitz game with a hardly a second
thought I mean it's just the it's the
ultimate human move then Knights
attacked your Kings a little exposed
your knight in front of your King no
more prepare for petrol checks nothing
to worry about but the computers point
out that in fact and in fact they are
right that the move rook b1 is simply
the best move the idea behind rook b1 is
that after Queen takes e - why give up
your night well after rook takes d7 hmm
there's just not a lot of joy in
Mudville over here you know I mean you
know I you know why it's just crashing
through and it's really that simple and
if we go back just a quick second of
course black would like to play King to
c7 but then after Bishop takes King
takes rook takes b7 resigns and after a
move like for example b5 now well it's
very clear and easy to see that well
with this night hanging on c6 you're not
very happy and if you could get black to
play rook b8 which you probably should
do then Knight g3 is an automat
medic but the inclusion of the moves
rook b1 and rook b8 are very favorable
for the first player excuse me we'll go
back here Knight g3 played Knight takes
rook here and now again his King in
order to save his King Queen f6 was was
necessary and going into an ending God
has an exchange up but again this guy
Hikaru man he's so resourceful he comes
up with with tricks from really
desperate positions and we have to give
God a credit because he just allows a
lot of squirming but no no no saving so
to speak so he's an exchange ahead his
rooks may not be beautiful or boastful
at the moment but the other problem more
concretely the problem for black is he
hasn't sold his King Bishop b5 attacking
the rook rook d1 very nicely threatening
a discovered check picking up the rook
there's no time for Bishop takes f1 King
c7 check and rook d1 night drop back to
c6 Bishop drop back to e4 very nicely
opening up the gate so to speak and rook
e8 rugby one idea of a4 here King G -
now here I again I think that Hikaru is
lost
yes I mean he's an exchange down but I
really don't like what happened here
there's Bishop going back to well h8 I
don't say that he's going to save the
game but sometimes desperate men you
know desperate times call for desperate
measures
in a sense blacks losing obviously
blacks losing the game but why not try
to put as much pressure on black as
possible and in this case I mean there
was idea of at least King a for King a
three or even some cases to play Knight
here and Knight takes offering to trade
this one for this one so Bishop h8
didn't get high marks from me rook h7 a3
and now rook takes okay if black and
obviously if black had had that extra
move King a4 he'd be doing reasonably
Knight eat and Knight e4 King takes
Knight c5 here I thought that gotta
played really really well
Bishop takes a six so the idea here is
that well it appears bishop takes a six
wins apiece White has the nice little
trick again remember when I criticized
the move Bishop h8 well it just happens
now that the bishop is on h8 why could
play rook b8 both black bishops are on
pre White's going to win back his piece
and then it's just going to be an
exchange and two pawns versus a minor
piece and pawn and easy win for white
Hikaru tried check King g1 here some
more moves and here essentially what God
is doing is consolidating just making
sure as king is very safe and winning
pawns king night-night check rook rook
95
h4 and here Hikaru resign so in a really
powerful performance by gada I'm just
not even sure he made any mistakes at
all I mean his play once he got into the
technical stages is play with superb
from the opening right through the
middle game his play made a really
really really powerful impression and I
don't want to harp on this one victory
from gotta he car was not in the best of
form he's played a lot and played very
successfully but in this tournament
it's what's what's he doing at the
moment Benny - two